-Our next guest is
an Emmy-winning writer,
director, and producer.
His latest movie,
"Please Don't Destroy:
The Treasure of Foggy Mountain,"
is streaming exclusively
on Peacock November 17th.
Let's take a look.
-I think I know where the
treasure of Foggy Mountain is,
and I think
we should go get it.
-The treasure of Foggy Mountain?
Like, from when we were kids?
-It all started
when I saw a TikTok
about this guy --
Deetch Nordwind.
-Whoa!
You have like 40 tabs open.
What are you doing, man?
-Well, that's how much
research I've been doing.
-Well, a lot of these are clips
from "Jennifer's Body."
Was that part of the research?
-Um...
-You could just rent the movie
at that point.
-Yeah.
-Enough.
-Please welcome
back to the show
our friend Judd Apatow,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
-Yes!
-I want to get to the movie,
but I also, I want
to start talking
about your very talented
daughter, Maude.
-Yes.
-Who was recently doing
"Cabaret" in London.
-That's right.
-Onstage in London.
-Look at that.
-That's thrilling.
That must be thrilling
as a father.
-Oh, my God, it's so exciting.
I went 12 times.
-Did you really go 12 times?
-I know.
The cast sometimes
would look at me out there
like, "Again?"
-Yeah.
So, tell me what it's like
as a father. Is it just...
Does it just fly by when you get
to watch a child onstage?
I mean, seeing it 12 times,
does it just feel amazing
every time?
-Uh, I'm so nervous
the first three or four times.
-Yeah.
-And then I can enjoy it.
And then by the end of the run,
I feel like it's some
major accomplishment of mine.
-Yes.
-You know?
So it's, like, really fun
'cause I don't have to do it,
but when it's over,
I'm like, "We did it."
[ Laughter ]
-Now, one of the reasons
you're here promoting the movie
is because of the SAG strike.
-There is a strike.
I don't know if you know.
-It's happening right now.
-Yes, and yes.
-It's a big strike.
And because of that,
the guys in the movie,
because they're SAG actors,
cannot promote the film.
You are a producer of the film,
so you can.
But because you can,
and only you can...
-I'm the only person
affiliated with the movie
who's allowed to talk
about the movie.
-Yeah.
-Everyone else has to pretend
it does not exist.
-Yeah.
And in fact, the three,
the Please Don't Destroy guys
will be here tomorrow,
and we're not gonna be able
to talk about it.
-You'd better not!
-We won't.
-I don't want you to mention.
-It'll be weird 'cause
I'm talking to you about it now
and they're gonna be here
tomorrow,
and they're gonna be like,
"Why is he not even
bringing it up?"
-Yeah.
-But because you're the only one
who can talk about it,
it has affected things like
the press at the premiere.
-Yeah, that's who showed up.
-Like...
-Just one guy who looks like
Evan Goldberg showed up.
That's it.
I mean, literally,
that's the entire press line.
And that's with me
standing there going,
"Please take my picture."
[ Laughter ]
-So, this is
one of the cool things.
The Please Don't Destroy guys,
who are wonderful --
two of them, John Higgins
and Martin Herlihy,
you know their dads.
-That's right.
-You've known their dads
forever.
-Yes.
John's dad is Steve Higgins,
the great producer
from "Saturday Night Live,"
from "The Tonight Show."
And Martin's dad is Tim Herlihy,
who wrote "The Wedding Singer"
and "Happy Gilmore."
-A famous SNL writer, as well.
-So it's very funny,
like, working with their kids
because they're young.
-Yeah.
-I am no longer young.
-And we would be sitting
in the woods
having these conversations,
and I would have flashbacks
of having the same conversations
with Adam Sandler and Tim,
like, "Hm, I've had
this boner conversation before.
I've debated this joke before."
-No, I will say,
I would not want to ever talk
to one of my dad's friends
about boners.
But if I had to,
I would think, like, Judd Apatow
would be the one.
Do they, like...?
-I would think that.
-Yeah.
-I would think that too.
But no matter what happens,
you're the creepy old guy.
-Yeah.
-You know? 'Cause, like...
-I also want to note, I know
that you filmed it in the woods,
but it was weird
that you started that by,
like, "We'd be in the woods
talking about it."
That didn't help.
-Well, no, no, no.
I would lure them
into the woods.
-You would lure them.
[ Laughter ]
I do want to talk about
maybe the fact
that you were having flashbacks.
These are some
of your early days.
-Well, this is when
I was their age.
-So, this is crazy.
This is when you were their age.
These are some of the people
you were hanging out with.
-Yeah. That's right.
-So, that's you.
And what do you got there?
-That's Shandling
and Springsteen at the Grammys.
-Wow.
-That's at the Grammys.
-And you were writing
at the Grammys?
-That's my first job ever,
writing the Grammys.
Obviously, I thought
I was kind of a cool
Sylvester Stallone type
at the time.
-And got away with it.
Not bad
-A little bit.
This is -- Was this writing
for "The Ben Stiller Show"?
-Yes, that's
"The Ben Stiller Show."
-So, you got Ben Stiller.
-And now you know
why I have a beard.
Because I look weird.
-Yeah. There you go.
-This is...
I mean, this is...
Look at this A-list crew
right here.
So, and this is on the set
of "The Larry Sanders Show."
-It's "The Larry Sanders Show."
And so that's with Gary,
and that's Warren Beatty,
and Rip Torn, and me, young.
But here's the thing.
You know, I am them there.
Right?
Like, so that's like
the Please Don't Destroy guys,
and I'm Rip Torn now.
-Yeah.
-Right?
-But you liked,
and I know from...
Because you were always,
as a kid,
fascinated with comedy.
You went out of your way
as a kid
to interview older comedians.
-Yes.
-So it must be weird.
I know you have a lot of respect
for younger comedians,
but are you still out there
trying to talk
to older comedians?
-Well, now I have
to make older friends
so I can still be the young guy.
-Yeah.
-That's my new thing.
-Wait, let me see.
Because I want to make sure
we have one. This is...
-So, now, in order
to be the young guy,
I have to hang out
with Mel Brooks.
-Yeah.
-And Dick Van Dyke
and Norman Lear.
That's 300 years of comedy
right there.
-They're literally
300 years old.
That's the only way you can
feel like John Higgins today
is to hang out with
300-year-old men.
-Yeah, and talk about...
And talk about World War II
for hours and hours.
-I bet you talk about boners
a little bit.
-But they're still
all way funnier than us.
-Yes.
-Like, not even close.
-It's really amazing.
I mean, it does...
You know, I've been lucky enough
to meet a couple of them,
and it's crazy how good they
still are at telling stories.
-Oh, yeah. Me and Bill Hader
went to visit Mel Brooks once,
and when we left, he said,
"Come, come visit again.
But not soon."
[ Laughter ]
"Like four months.
Wait four months."
[ Laughter ]
And this was my group of, like,
Please Don't Destroy.
This is us when we were young.
-And you've been opening
for Adam Sandler recently
on the road.
He's doing a standup tour,
and you've been opening for him
for 40 years.
Is that true?
-Yeah, I mean, I literally
started doing standup...
It'll be -- In a year
and a half, it'll be 40 years.
-Wow.
-Since the first time.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I always think that anything
that's like 40 years earlier...
I always think like,
if this was the '70s,
I'd be talking
about W.C. Fields.
-Yeah.
-Like, it's too much.
And the sad part is,
it's been 40 years
and I'm still opening for Adam.
You know?
It never, like, reversed.
-It never flipped.
You never got anybody
who would open for you.
-No, that's not possible.
But I lately have been thinking
I should stop doing standup,
and I've been, like,
kind of making a list,
like pros and cons of,
like, should I quit?
-Oh, that's interesting.
And so these are the reasons
why I should quit.
-Should?
-Yes.
"Too bad a memory to remember
jokes; must read off paper."
-Yeah.
-"Nothing to say."
-Nothing to say.
-"Too rich to bother
writing jokes."
-Yeah.
That'll get in the way.
-"Don't know who Doja Cat is."
-Yeah.
Who -- Who does?
-"No endgame."
-[ Laughs ]
-"Hard to do with sciatica."
-Yeah.
-"All my references
are from the 1900s."
-Yeah.
-"The verdict is in --
I'm not charismatic."
-Oh, well, I would wait that out
a little bit, yeah.
-The last one is,
"Sick of riding in buses
with Rob Schneider."
-Yeah,
-Which is actually
kind of fun.
-This is a crazy photo,
because this is
the 1992 "Young Comedians."
-That's right.
-And I mean, I...
Everybody here had a career.
It's a really impressive
group of people.
-That's right. Yeah.
And look at Carvey.
Carvey looks the same.
-Yeah.
-Look at me.
-The difference.
-It is haunting
how much different you look
and how much the same he looks.
-Yeah.
This is the thing.
Here's my other list.
Ready?
-You have two lists.
-My second list, which I can't
remember, which is, you know,
you have to stop doing standup
at a certain age
'cause all your jokes
become about decay.
-Yeah.
-Right?
Because you -- that's all
you know in life, is decay.
And so all your jokes
are kind of like,
"Hey, isn't diverticulitis
funny?"
-Yeah.
-"Don't you hate it
when all your girlfriends
from high school
start dying of natural causes?"
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good one.
I like that one.
I mean, I don't know
if it's a closer,
'cause everybody's
super bummed out, but...
[ Both laugh ]
-It's both.
-It is a delight
to have you here.
Congrats on the movie.
That's Judd Apatow, everybody.
-"Please Don't Destroy:
The Treasure of Foggy Mountain"
begins streaming exclusively
on Peacock November 17th.
We'll be right back with music
from Rett Madison.